[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mardi 30
octobre de l'histoire et de l'art
contemporain le château de versailles
accueille en ce moment même deux
expositions dans le domaine le roi
louis-philippe côtoient l'architecte et
photographes
hiroshi sugimoto blues sur seine c'est
du 9 au 24 novembre le festival revient
pour sa vingtième édition 26 rendez-vous
33 artistes et près de 20 villes nous
découvrirons la programmation avec notre
invité
musique encore avec notre deuxième
invité le clae siens gars vous qui a
sorti le temps des songes son dernier
album de rap 15 titres disponibles sur
les plateformes digitales du château de
versailles on en retient surtout son
concepteur louis xiv mais d'autres
monarques ont marqué son histoire
louis-philippe n'y a jamais vécu
mais il y a laissé son empreinte en
transformant le palais en musée une
exposition lui est consacrée jusqu'au 3
février
marylène via piccino pour les images
c'est une page plutôt méconnu du château
de versailles
après un pâle et un lieu d'habitation le
domaine devient musée ouvert à tous les
publics
le roi louis-philippe peuvent partager à
ses contemporains l'histoire de france
c'est la fabrique de l'histoire lui
philippe il fabrique notre histoire
d'aujourd'hui avec des différents
épisodes différents chapitres alors
après on peut les commenter les juger
mais lui nous livre comme l'a dit victor
hugo il ouvre le livre de l'histoire de
france pour nous inauguré en 1837 ce
château et pensé par le dernier
souverain avoir régné louis-philippe
transforme profondément le lieu il fait
aménager les appartements des courtisans
en galerie vous vous immerger dans les
salles qu'il a créé et donc vous voyez
ce qu'il a voulu faire du château de
versailles
puisque vous découvrez 32 nouvelles
salles près de 5000 m² qui étaient des
sales qui n'était plus ouverte au public
ou pas toujours ouverte au public tels
que la salle des croisades qu'elle tels
que la grande galerie des batailles ou
tel que les salles
d'afrique dans ses salles des tableaux
commandés des oeuvres rapatriés par le
monarque
l'exposition permet de découvrir
l'histoire avec un grand h
à travers celle personnelle d'un roi
c'est une première à versailles pour son
exposition d'art contemporain le château
accueille un photographe
hiroshi sugimoto il explore six lieux du
domaine un reportage de manon varaldo
découvrir le domaine de trianon
autrement pour sa 11e exposition d'art
contemporain le château de versailles
ouvre des lieux inédits
le petit trianon le belvédère le
pavillon français accueillent les
personnages fictifs et les oeuvres
contemporaines d'hiroshi sugimoto la
zone du trianon n'a jamais été utilisée
avant mais maintenant c'est disponible
donc j'ai décidé d'utiliser plus
l'intimité des espaces de versailles par
rapport à la grandeur de paris depuis
2008 le château de versailles reçoit un
artiste français ou étrangers et 2018
marque le 160e anniversaire des
relations diplomatiques entre la france
et le japon
cette exposition est donc un mariage
original entre ces deux cultures
cette année c'est l'année japonisme
comme vous le savez qui consacre la
relations culturelles entre la france et
le japon
on dit que l mais les amants résonance
et bien je crois que le château de
versailles par cette exposition d'art
contemporain illustre tout à fait ce
propos
desvres des sculptures il est aussi
question de portraits hiroshi sugimoto
aime les capter en noir et blanc
l'artiste japonais présente les ombres
des grands personnages qui ont marqué
habiter ou qui ont traversé ces lieux à
l'image de louis xiv le temps d'une
exposition le passé reprend vie
c'est une de mes pièces de sculptures
ces outils house à la porte le sens
japonais du design à l'espace et au
jardin afin d'être ressenti dans
l'étendue de versailles
c'est un beau contraste de jouer entre
la sensibilité française et la
sensibilité japonaise de l'espace
d'autres oeuvres sont à découvrir comme
celle qui a donné son nom à l'exposition
surface de révolution l'artiste investit
les jardins du domaine de trianon
jusqu'au 17 février
on continue cette sculpture avec notre
invité stéphane demain ges le directeur
de blues sur seine
un festival qui fête cette année ses 20
ans bonjour exact 20 ans alors ça succès
qui se dément pas pour que cette
septième depuis 20 ans bah écoutez on a
la chance d'avoir le soutien du public
donc on en profite on continue à essayer
de développer de belles choses et
justement plus de 30 artistes cette
année de nombreuses villes en valant
vallée de seine une belle programmation
mais couteau merci on essaye voix basse
et c'est le but d'essayer de développer
cette esthétique du blues justement
comment on va les chercher les artistes
c'est eux qui viennent c'est la
programmation les programmateurs qui
vont les chercher
c'est un peu des deux en fait c'est à
dire que au début on a des idées qu'on a
envie d'avoir ce festival
puis il ya des artistes des fois qu'ils
nous appellent qui proposent leurs
projets on discute on écoute on écoute
beaucoup ça c'est un penchant de notre
métier cas c'est cool et puis voilà en
france décide alors justement vous
écouter beaucoup ya que des amateurs de
blues dans les équipes de programmation
ou contraire ça brasse large pour avoir
des mois déjà de balle je veux pas de
forcément du blues moi j'ai commencé ma
carrière dans le rap
je travaillais dans des boîtes de
production pour le rap après j'ai appris
historiquement je vais j'ai fait
beaucoup de rock dans mes équipes
il ya des fans de musique du monde à
défendre on écoute de tout en fait et je
pense que c'est je pense que c'est la
mauvaise idée d'écouter que du blues on
va se fermer à des choses superbes et
voilà donc voilà on est on écoute de
tous dans l'équipe tout le monde a sa
petite très fier de préférence mais ça
permet d'avoir un autre regard et
d'autres écoutent faut que ça fonctionne
depuis 20 ans qu'est ce qui plaît dans
le blues bah écoutez ça je sais pas
faudrait demande au public mais non
après bolt on ne fait pas que du blues
nous on fait du blues ont fait beaucoup
d'autres styles différents
même s'appelle bleus sur cette voie ça
commençait sur du blues après qu'est ce
qui plaît chez pas c'est un rendez vous
aussi c'est un rendez vous que les gens
attendent
et puis c'est on travaille toujours sûr
de la qualité en tout cas on essaye donc
je pense que le public c'est trop bas
alors dans la programmation il ya des
têtes d'affiché lisa simone rhoda scott
ou encore keziah jones
ça fait aussi venir j'imagine pas
forcément des artistes internationaux
comme ça c'est les premiers billets qui
partent un donc bien sûr c'est aussi le
festival et c'est aussi le jeu des
festives en votre guise de faire venir
cette tête d'affiche qui raconte quelque
chose
d'ailleurs voilà par exemple rhoda scott
est une habituée du festival et elle
aime le festival aussi dans son
esthétique et danse qui se propage donc
voilà qu'il a une histoire très lié avec
rhoda scott sur le festival puisque l'un
des créateurs de blues sur seine qui
mène on ne travaille plus dans le social
qui suis quand même et son manager donc
voilà c'est ça qui vient au festival
c'est qu'il ya des histoires c'est pas
juste on festival où il ya une
programmation et une billetterie là il
ya des histoires qui se crée notamment
avec notre travail qu'on essaye de faire
avec les scolaires les publics scolaires
ou les publics empêchés faire ça dépasse
le concert en tout cas on essaie de
d'install d'instaurer un dialogue à
travers la musique c'est aussi 10 à
simone avec un patronyme très connu oui
les à simone la fille de la célèbre nina
qui mais qui n'a pas commencé par le
le blues est là parce qu'elle vu qu'elle
est vétérante de l'armée américaine mais
je pense que ces jeunes l'ont rattrapé
elle a bien fait parce que ce qu'ils
proposent c'est vraiment super
bah ouais après bon avec les jeunes
qu'elle a c'est quelque part c'est
facile et keziah jones by keziah jones
et voilà je le présente même pas ça sert
à rien tout le monde le connaît c'est un
génie de la musique ça gêne et du blues
du jazz lui forcément on n'est pas
inquiet sur le spectacle vivant
le principe aussi du festival c'est les
artistes émergents ou quelques noms
d'artistes émergents louis basset de
notre c'est notre notre notre travail
ben moi j'ai un boulot ce que j'aime
beaucoup que j'avais pu parlait déjà ici
c'était un crime burrows kim heureuse
parce que aussi il ya une histoire une
histoire qui est magnifique c'est qu'il
ya un grand nom elles étendent études
pour devenir infirmière et tu la sors un
album génial
elle a une voix spectaculaire et les
gens se trompent pas parce que nous
sommes là mais elle est partout en
france et les salles se remplissent
encore il ya quelques temps donc voilà
donc donc voila et vous avez eu la
primeur et on a aussi par exemple c'est
pas ça râle un cas sarah lagacé une voix
c'est un petit bout de femme qui est
parti dans des jazz club vivre en
londres et puis qui revenue ici
fall a une signature vocale en dehors du
fait que l a un talent qui n'est plus à
prouver elle à grain de voix particulier
ce qu'a fait c'est juste un oui je sais
vous avez cité deux artistes
on va écouter d'abord sarah lenka cette
fameuse chanteuse avec une voix très
particulière
[Musique]
m
oui
étiez le
et c'est les artistes émergents il ya
une encore une autre facette parmi
toutes les facettes du festival aider
les plus jeunes encore bien tremplin
chez vous c'est donc tous les artistes
émergents c'est des professionnels qu'à
blâmer
voilà quel média les tout jeunes aussi
qui s'associe au oui le tremplin par
rapport à sa moyenne s'élève nous on
travaille sur un tremplin pour justement
faire émerger de nouvelles scènes
donc voilà donc on a six participants
qui vont s'affronter avec une chaufferie
qui rassemble à la fois des gens du
milieu associatif mais aussi des
professionnels avec des blogueurs des
agents d'artistes
tout ça pour avoir aussi un regard qui
n'est pas que sclérosé j'avais à dire
sur notre notre notre association à nous
donc donc voila et on va décerner trois
prix donc le prix de mesures c'est
depuis ce qu'on appelle le prix
révélation ou là on va choisir un gros
puis on va l'accompagner pendant un an
sur du développement en le faisant on
s'adapte à l'artiste mais on va lui
faire enregistrer des sons va le faire
répéter on va y apportant un soutien
administratif
donc voilà puis après on a deux autres
prix au prix qu'on appel aux mécènes
parce que c'est nos mécènes qui nous
soutiennent et on les remercie encore
ici de soutenir le festival qui vont
choisir un artiste et pour le mettre en
avant sur la prochaine édition est le
dernier prix qui le prix est ce que j ça
c'est un prix qu'on a en collaboration
avec l'office franco québécois et parce
qu'on a un échange d'artistes franco
québécois donc on nous envoie un artiste
au québec et le québec nous avons un
artiste échelle donc voilà tout ça pour
développer cette cette scène vraiment
émergentes et voilà une scène qui se
développe en plus dans de nombreuses
années de nombreuses villes oui tout à
développer vos partenariats
c'est très ancré le festival bat we weed
man où on est un festival seront comme
on aime à dire itinérant c'est à dire
que on reste pas sur une ville nous on
est surtout leur vie sur tous les
territoires des yvelines pour nous ça
nous semble importante puisque le but
aussi du festival c'est d'apporter la
culture
enfin voilà donc dont la porte on est
soutenue par beaucoup de villes donc
donc c'est un jeu qui aussi qui plaît et
ça fait de beaux spectacles
merci stéphane gomez alors blues sur
seine arrive à grands pas premier rendez
vous le vendredi 9 novembre ça se passe
à rosny sur seine et à poissy toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
site internet du festival du blues aussi
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
david lescot signer un portrait contée
et chantée d'une légende
nina simone la comédienne ludmila dabo
incarne la célèbre chanteuse anne
hommage à découvrir le 6 novembre une
création à la ferme de bel ébat j'ai
rencontré dieu d'ahmed madani le metteur
en scène raconte l'histoire de nina une
adolescente mélancolique
la jeune fille rencontre amar sur
facebook à marle invite à le suivre dans
la guerre qu'il mène au nom d'un idéal
religieux la pièce évoque les faux
semblants les apparences la spiritualité
c'est une pièce contemporaine sur des
événements forts de la société
d'aujourd'hui
et puis sur la manipulation j'ai choisi
traiter cette thématique parce que en
fait c'est la fameuse trilogie qui
s'appelle face à leur destin et il ya
une pièce qui s'appelle flamme que nous
avons que nous voulons tourner
actuellement et donc il y avait un le
pendant de cette pièce qui serait une
petite pièce qui s'appelle donc j'ai
rencontré dieu sur facebook et qui pose
une réflexion sur la transmission du
point du mas très linéaire la grand mère
la mère et la fille et ça met en scène
ben eu une maman qui est d'origine
algérienne et puis qui est qui qui a
épousé un français et donc la jeune
fille qui est qui qui naît de leur union
elle est en quête de son origine elle se
pose la question d'où elle vient
propos recueillis par marylène il ya
pichenot le prix goncourt est l'un des
plus prestigieux prix littéraire remis
en france a pris qui se destinent qui se
décline à destination des lycéens depuis
1988 des élèves âgés de 15 à 18 ans
lisent et étudie les ouvrages
sélectionnés cette année une classe de
seconde du lycée de la plaine de nos
flattera fait partie du jury viendront
non plus de 4000 pages à lire en deux
mois cette seconde du lycée de la plaine
de neauphle ne chôme pas depuis la
rentrée elle participe au prix découvre
des lycéens avec leur professeur de
lettres
pour une fois la lecture ça sort du
cadre scolaire de la lecture analytique
de lecture linéaire du comment à
composer tout ça c'est autre chose
l'idée c'est de ses de retrouver une
forme de liberté par rapport au livre
parce que parce que souvent il est vécue
dans la scolarité comme étant une forme
de contrainte
le 15 novembre un lauréat recevra le
prix avant il faut lire découvert de
nouvelles techniques des lectures et
échanges avec leurs professeurs et
organisations de l'emploi du temps j sur
ton mercredi après midi parce qu'on a on
n'a pas cours le samedi aussi dimanche
du cousin premier week-end mais c'est
pas grave c'est qu'on aura fini bon sera
content
je me suis relié avec eux mon bon mon
camarade en groupe de deux ans on dit
ben dis vive les quinze livres on lit
pas comme si on lisait un livre
normalement en fait on lit on y vite et
on saute d on peut sauter des
paragraphes ou des passages des pages
pour les aider dans leurs choix les 30
trappistes ont pu rencontrer les auteurs
durant une journée sur paris ils ont pu
poser des questions lors de conférences
d'enrichir ma culture déjà le savoir
aussi du coup quand je lis un lit je me
poserai différentes questions des
questions que j'ai pas forcément que je
me suis pas forcément posée avant j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant parce qu'on
pouvait voir
leur esprit en fait ce qu'ils pensaient
vraiment en écrivant leurs livres et
c'était intéressant de jouer ça n'a rien
à voir avec les rencontres avec les
adultes ils sont beaucoup plus spontané
arriver vraiment encore un mois de
lectures avant de devoir faire un choix
avec le prix goncourt des lycéens
certains élèves ont renforcé leur amour
de la lecture d'autres l'ont découvert
animateurs le jour rappeur la nuit gare
loup originaire des clayes-sous-bois
sort un nouvel album et il est en
plateau avec nous pour en parler bonjour
bonjour alors le titre de ce nouvel
album le temps des songes
c'est bien ça le temps de songes en fait
c'est un hommage un peu à la culture de
nouvelle calédonie fait indigènes donc
voilà je voulais faire un clin d'oeil à
ça le temps des songes le temps des
rêves
en fait pourquoi la nouvelle calédonie
c'est un pays que vous connaissez ou non
non mais c'est juste en fait j'ai trouvé
là la culture aborigène assez
intéressante d'un point de vue humain et
voilà j'avais envie de leur faire
incarner alors dans cet album quinze
titres autoproduit
vous évoquez la musique l'insomnie la
mort qu'est ce qui vous a inspiré pour
écrire en partie bas les choses qui se
sont passées on va dire dans ma vie et
je pense que c'est des titres aussi et
des thèmes qui concernent un peu un peu
pas mal de personnes donc on est un peu
tous concerné par ça et puis ben voilà
c'est vraiment l'inspiration de la vie
quoi en fait la vie en général pour
raconter des histoires dans vos chansons
ce sont des instants de vie
moi j'aime beaucoup en fait tout ce qui
est storytelling en fait dans les
morceaux
c'est à dire j'aime beaucoup
raconter une histoire du début à la fin
j'aime aussi on va dire les films twist
ending donc j'aime beaucoup raconté une
histoire qui débute bien et qui termine
mal voilà on s'attend pas forcément à ce
genre de son coin nord américain ce
titre on va écouter un extrait on en
parle à juste après avec pourrait faire
de belles balades
cette phase est en jeu
il met chaque erreur me faire
en termes codés
nos vies soient remplies de beauté là
qu'ils ont partagés j'étais très fier un
joueur gouvernement à la fois galère
mais cela va bien on mange et je tourne
je vis pour est restée comme tous ici je
me braque la foule
on vient d'écouter avancer avancer
oui c'est on va dire c'est le morceau
c'est un des morceaux d'ouverture de
l'album en fait où en fait dans la vie
faut qu'on avance en fait et j'ai pris
en fait un peu toutes les erreurs que
j'ai faites dans ma vie c'est vraiment
un album qui est assez personnel mais
j'ai pris un peu toutes les erreurs que
j'ai faites dans ma vie pour pour les
raconter en fait paris mais en fait et
voilà je trouve qu'on a tous besoin en
fait d'avancé que ce soit
professionnellement ça soit humainement
que ça soit dans tout musicalement et
voilà j'ai même mis mon fils dans le
clip
donc pour moi c'est un symbole et puis
c'est important la plus personnelle plus
dur à écrire peut-être un l'album a été
plus dure à sentir le contraire tout
était couché sur le papier ou son
téléphone comme celle que vous écrivez
avant j'écrivais sur papier donc j'ai
vraiment les boules et des cahiers des
cahiers pendant des années puis c'est
vrai que maintenant avec le téléphone
c'est plus simple maintenant donc j'ai
écrit en fait les morceaux j'ai écrit
les quinze morceaux avant de les
enregistrer c'est à dire que je suis
partie en studio aux ninjas squad dos jo
c'est un studio qui a aux
clayes-sous-bois qui est qui est régie
par john s voilà j'ai fait une dédicace
et en fait j'ai écrit les quinze
morceaux et puis après je pense y
enregistrer les quinze nations alors
c'est un nouvel album ce qui signifie
que c'est pas le premier vous sortez
votre première mixtape en 2008 d'où
vient cet amour de la musique et du rap
particulièrement en fait j'ai été on va
dire bercé en fait bas j'ai grandi j'ai
grandi à plaisir dans le quartier de la
haise est déjà dans ce quartier il y
avait déjà des groupes de rap qui se
formaient à l'époque donc j'ai commencé
en fait à a aimé a aimé l'écriture et
puis j'ai écouté aussi va pas mal de rap
donc voilà entre autres 1 tm paris sous
les bombes donc vraiment les albums on
va dire pionnier et du coup ça m'a donné
envie d'écrire ça m'a donné envie de me
révolter ça m'a donné des envies en fait
deux voilà d'écriture de voilà en gros
si vous faites un peu de scènes ya eu la
clé des champs à plaisir est ce que vous
continuez c'est un c'est un instant que
vous appréciez
c'est un instant qui est assez difficile
pour moi la scène parce que je suis
quelqu'un d'assez introverti un assez
timide 1 malgré ce que je peux montrer
en dehors mais en fait oui j'ai fait des
scènes donc à la clé des champs à
l'ancienne clé des champs donc je salue
philippe guillonneau qui était voilà
c'était mon mentor et j'ai fait une
scène la dernière à la verrière donc
pour un copain moi parce qu'il m'a pas
dire qu'il m'a tiré un petit peu mais
oui je suis pas contre la scène il faut
juste que je sois à l'aise voilà c'est
ça vous citiez ntm est ce qu il yad
autres références des aspirations
peut-être dans les rappeurs
d'aujourd'hui qui vous inspirent au
contraire vous avez cherché dans la
première génération de rappeurs français
il ya des rappeurs de la première
génération qui sont encore là
aujourd'hui mais dont on ne parle pas
forcément moi je
beaucoup inspiré enfin pourquoi inspiré
je suis beaucoup j'aime beaucoup casey
par exemple qui n' rappeuse que je
respecte énormément de par le message
qu'elle délivre et puis elle est restée
toujours sur une constante en fait et
puis iam
j'aime beaucoup parce que si c'est des
pionniers puis ils ont des vrais
messages à passer et je trouve en fait
tous que le rap en fait conscient pour
moi c'est le top en fait du rapport au
ces par exemple city très très bon alors
cet album là et tout récent mais ce
qu'on a un nouveau en préparation pour
le moment c'est un peu de repos aussi
pour pour l'imagination
ouais il va y avoir je pense qu'il va y
avoir un peut-être un prochain projet on
verra pour l'instant c'est vrai que je
pars plus sur des réalisations pas ce
que je fais de la réalisation de clips
aussi donc je tente plus sur la
réalisation de clips et j'aimerais aussi
développé un peu des artistes
indépendants et les aider les
producteurs peut-être ouais voilà les
aider un peu à se développer les aider à
faire un petit peu de 2 comme les aider
à
je pense que c'est important aussi
d'aider les autres voilà comme on m'a
aidé merci gars nous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors je le rappelle
vous sortez un nouvel album le temps des
songes
il est disponible sur toutes les
plateformes digitales on passe
maintenant à notre agenda
[Musique]
le 31 octore c'est halloween une bonne
occasion de se retrouver entre amis de
glaner des bonbons et pourquoi pas de se
faire peur au cinéma les
clayes-sous-bois propose des projections
frissonnante et notamment pour les plus
jeunes chair de poule 2 inspirée de la
collection littéraire de rl stine on
regarde un extrait des phénomènes
mystérieux se sont déroulés récemment à
madison dans l'est de la mer
la ville a été envahie par les créatures
de manuscrits originaux de rl stine le
vivre quels livres
c'est un chair de poule viennent serrure
c'est pas vrai qu'est ce que tu as fait
il est grand temps car il ne dira pour
toujours
à montigny le bretonneux on joue du
sacha guitry nicolas briançon met en
scène et joue un avocat séduisant une
femme mariée à découvrir le mardi 6
novembre
nous parlons avec les yeux ou trois
semaines ça fait des conversations
autrement dit nous paie
[Musique]
nous avons passé toute la nuit ensemble
ça c'est le côté charmante avant tout
devait rentrer chez moi on a la une à la
presse que vous allez prendre du baril
est effroyable et tout baltard oui au
front
d'aveux 3 voilà un autre rendez vous de
la musique avec les bons becs le groupe
créé en 1992 mais le fantasy créativité
variété et musique classique big bang
s'écoute le mardi 6 novembre au théâtre
alphonse daudet de quoi dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un clin d'oeil à présent à alfred sisley
l'artiste peintre et graveur anglais
s'installe à l'ancienne en 1869 puis à
marly le roi devenu chroniqueur de la
vie de ces villes y rencontre des
événements les inondations la neige le
brouillard
vous voyez quelques toiles à l'écran et
le 30 octobre c'est son anniversaire
celui de sa naissance
alfred sisley mai à paris en 1839 une
dernière information avant de nous
quitter les médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines ferme à partir du
lundi 5 novembre un nouveau site
internet est un nouveau logiciel sont en
cours d'installation
la réouverture est prévue le 11 novembre
prochain c'est la fin de cette fuite
culture merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]